hello everyone I know we're in the
middle of covering the Bobby Fischer
series and the bill chest festival so it
might be odd to add again from yet
another tournament into the schedule but
I thought it was important to cover this
one it's a game from round three of the
Donahoe international Grandmaster
tournament is being placed from 27th of
July to 3rd of August it's being played
in the than Java on the South China Sea
island province of Hainan and it's an
eight-player single round-robin where
the prize fund is sixty thousand dollars
and twenty thousand dollars goes to the
winner of the tournament here we have a
game between vd2 Gujarati and same
Shanklin same Shanklin you know he won
to the US Chess Championship so he is
the reigning US Champion and it's
interesting that so far in 2018 he did
not lose a single game and he has been
undefeated for the for the previous 62
games so quite you know quite a nice
unbeaten streak and he faces with it
with it Gujarati who is the India's
third highest rated Grandmaster and the
fourth Grandmaster from India to ever
cross the 2700 rating the only higher
rated chess players in India after you
know aside from Gujarati are Vishwanath
Anand who is the highest rated and
pentola Hari Krishna so without further
ado let's check out this game we even do
have a photo of the game there we have
it it's the only two moves have been
played it's it's taken from keep i.org
that see and so feel free to check it
out if you feel like it so yeah that's
that's the photo let's check out the
game see for the English opening c6 the
kurakin defence against the English d4
and d5 transposing into the slop a
knight to f3 Knight to f6 III Bishop to
g4 h3 Black has to decide whether to go
back with the bishop or to capture on f3
we have captures captures and now e6
so here you can see Franklin got rid of
his light square bishop he put all his
pawns on light squares and now his dark
square bishop will be able to cruise
along
you know in between them Knight to c3
brush up to be for pinning the night and
now Knight Bishop to d3 we have castles
castles and the night beat 37 and here
while white does have a lot of options
here white plays are most interesting
move Queen to d1 definitely a home
preparation as it is an one of ancients
favorite we have Queen to e7 and now
Queen to b3 so interesting Bishop
captures an f3 queen goes to f3 then
Queen goes back to the one then Queen
goes to b3 you know and it's only move
11 we have
rook to b8 so now the bishop from before
can move and the b7 pawn will not be
under attack
c5 opening now the Queen is no longer
guarding the bishop on b4 so the Queen
is attacking it Bishop to a5 and now
Queen to a for attacking the bishop yet
again rush up to c7 and now F for
improving the control of d5 square we
have a 5 a 3 preparing to put b4 at some
point rook to e8 and now comes Bishop to
d2 rook the error group comes to b8 we
have a queen - C - preparing to pull
before black cannot close this with a 4
because the knight and queen both are
attacking the a Foursquare so b6 and now
comes B for a capture some before a
capture some before he captures on c5 b
captures on c5 and now not exchanging
the rooks immediately but first Bishop
to a5 we have looked to a for preparing
to double rooks on the a file and
Shanklin captures on c3 Bishop captures
the bishop captures and now Knight to f8
we have rook F to a1 we did double
strokes on the a file
rook captures the rook captures in the
Knight to g6 and Bishop to a5 now you
can see that here gujrati has two
bishops against two nights so as it is a
pretty close position
you know this light square bishop
doesn't seem like it has all that much
to do all of these pawns or on dark
squares the knight should definitely be
better but Gujerati finds a very nice
plan and he transfers this bishop from
c3
all the way to d6 here
so let's see how he does it Bishop to a5
we have rook to e8 and now comes a
Bishop to b6 offering to trade rooks
Queen b7 we have Queen 282 now for
single rope trade or otherwise rook to
a7 will be coming our capture screen
captures and Knight to e7 now Queen to
a5 we have King to f8 and now comes
Bishop to c7 a nice to e8 would a double
attack on the bishop and now comes a
Bishop to d6 so now the bishop is a very
active piece and it's not all that easy
to get rid of it for example you can
simply capture it or or when white
captures back you have just lost the
game wherever you move the knight it's
gonna be Queen - Queen to d8 checkmate
so after Bishop to d6 we have f5 making
some breeding space for the Queen and
also not allowing this better friend e3
to target to the h7 pawn Queen to d8 now
with a double attack against the e7
night and we have King to f7 unpinning
and here again a very nice move by
Gujrati
Bishop to a6 trying to deflect the Queen
here if you capture of course you will
lose the game immediately after King g6
capturing here and well you can go here
and get checkmated in 6 moves or you can
go here and you will get checkmated in
one move so which you know if you
already have this option make it and
make it a nice one bunch of to a6 and
now Queen to a7 of course not accepting
the this very nice offering King to h2
knife to f6 we have Queen to b6 offering
a trade of Queens and Queen to d7
of course not trading Queens if you
trade Queens here then after C capture
some b6 the bishops are controlling all
of the squares at this point and needs
to be promoted to a queen so of course
you are you are lost here as black after
Queen b6 we have Queen to d7 declining
in the trade Queen to be 8 and here
comes Knight f2 g8 it's not all that
easy to find a move here for black you
should play something like g6 make some
more breeding Square a breathing space
for the king
you get Bishop captures and after Queen
captures you get well brush of the b7
I'm going after the c6 bone
and now you have to be very careful or
black will play nice the g4 check and
here you see you can't capture the night
you have to move the King and then black
will have some counter play after night
captures on e3 because if you capture
then of course it will be a draw by
repetition of moves and black will be
very happy to achieve this but of course
it doesn't work as you don't have to
play it better to be seven and of course
you don't have to capture the night but
you know and no point in in in doing it
if you know you're not sure about it so
night f2g eight I would have came to g1
and now Queen to e8 offering a trade of
Queens but here it would actually suit
black Queen to a7 now again painting the
seven night we have Queen to d8 and now
Bishop the b7 threatening to capture the
c6 pawn as the knight here would be
pinned King g6 on pinning and now Queen
to a6
again with a double attack against the
c6 pawn queen t8 defending the c6 pawn
and now King to f1 we have h6 Queen to
b6 King to h7 and now Queen comes the c7
white slowly but surely improves the
position of his pieces King back to g6
King to d1 King to h5 and now comes a
rush up to a six we have King to g6 and
now you either have to be satisfied with
a repetition of moves or you have to
push push for the win here and we're at
e it goes for it he plays g4 and here
you probably want to play something like
F captures H captures bring the King
over to f7 and allow white simply keep
on improving on his position and
Shanklin knows that a Gujarati is much
better here so he doesn't go for this
he plays Queen to a8 which seems like a
terrible terrible blunder but it's the
only hope for black it seems as he has
to give up some material in order to
perhaps you know have be able to draw
this game by by checking the White King
and repeating moves so let's see what
happened here
Bishop captures Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures and now of
course these six ponies undefended
so Queen captures on e6 with check we
have King moves and now Queen captures
on f7 with chair
King moose now as a slight reputation of
moves queen f8 check King moves Queen a5
check King moves and now comes g5 so to
push you have to allow back to give some
checks Queen e1 Queen a1 check King f2
Queen to be to check king of three and
now Queen to c1 you do have to allow
white a move here pretty much any move
will be sufficient for white Gujarati
goes for g6 now threatening a queen to
f8 or Queen to see a checkmate doesn't
really matter we have Queen to f1 check
King moves Queen to g2 check King moose
quintal e to check and now Queen to g4
of course black is done material he
cannot afford to trade Queens but at
least he prevented checkmate as the
Queen had to block we have king to h4 a
very nice move you can't threaten
anything with the Queen immediately
because then black Queen will harass the
white king once again so first King to
h4 getting the King to a nice dark
square Queen to a 8 and now Queen to d7
again putting the black in in sort of a
tube swung as the the the black queen is
now stuck regarding this this exponent
the black Queen is stuck regarding the
entire eighth rank any move by the Queen
and the eighth rank will be checkmate
so black doesn't really have all that
many moves sure you can waste a move
with the king but it will not help you
here we have h5 trying to give up a pawn
but in Gujrat it doesn't really doesn't
really want it immediately we have King
to g8 King to f3 and now h4 Queen to e6
check King to h8 and now Queen to e7 and
it was in this position that Samuel
Shanklin or same Shanklin yeah I believe
same Shanklin this is full name it's not
like short for Samuel but I will have to
check I'm pretty sure it's same Shanklin
resigned the game actually resigned
because there's nothing to do here after
any move you make you seen the pot this
pawn will be captured and then white
will be simply up too much material
being up three pawns is too much yeah
after Queen to e7 he resigned the game
and this is his first loss of the
year 2018 and it was to visit gujarati
of India so there you have it after 62
games going undefeated you know the
streak finally ended now some of you may
not know this some of you may do know
this the person who holds the record for
highest for a largest unbeaten streak is
actually Michael Todd and the person who
holds the record for highest and you
know longest on a second unbeaten streak
is also Michael Todd so there you have
it so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it this was just you know I will
not be covering this tournament like
anymore it's just one I had to show
since you know breaking an unbeaten
streak of 62 games you know it's
definitely something to show so I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check - on my previous video er think
all for watching and I will see you soon
returning to the bill chest festival and
the Bobby Fischer series thank you all
and I'll see you soon